حي الصناعه في مدينه جنديرس هذا الحي
المدمر بشكل شبه كامل يعني البناء الذي
سلم ولم يدمر ولم يسوى بالارض قد هدم يعني
واصبح غير صالحا للسكن كهذا البناء الذي
يظهر امامكم على الشاشه طبعا تستمر فرق
الدفاع المدني في انتشال الضحايا من بعض
المباني اما بالنسبه للمباني التي تم
مسحها بشكل كامل كهذا الحي حيث تم مسح
جميع المباني وانتشال الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض تستمر فرق الدفاع المدني
بالانتشار في هذه النقاط ايضا
تحسبا لاي ابلاغ قد ياتيهم من احد عن وجود
ضحايا تحت الانقاض في احد الابنيه طبعا
تشاهدون الان ايضا الاهالي هنا الذين اتوا
الى الى احيائهم ال ال هؤلاء الناجين من
هذا الزلزال الذين اتوا الى هذا الحي منهم
من اراد ان يدخل الى منزله واخذ ما يمكن
اخذه من من المنزل بغيت الاستفاده منه في
المكان الذي لجاوا اليه سواء كان خيمه او
مركز ايواء او حتى عند احد من اقاربهم